here in Israel we had a horrifying
Massacre of Israelis and it is until
today almost a month had passed and we
don't have the exact number of how many
people were killed Hamas is publishing
numbers every day how do they know how
many people were killed in each and
every attack how do they know that these
were all civilians the numbers that are
coming out of Gaza include the 1500
terrorists that invaded into Israel and
slaughtered our families the numbers
that are coming out of Gaza include the
Hamas terrorists that are fighting
against the IDF now nobody knows what's
the numbers exactly the distinction
between civilians and terrorists how
they were killed nobody knows and
everybody just view Israel as
responsible and I think it's important
to look at the details in this picture
for all of us to be capable of defeating
Terror